the power of uh Legacy and name
recognition people who look you can't
sell a product no one knows about
everybody knows what the New York time
is New York Times is so they want they
want to read the news they just buy that
and they don't realize they're being
lied to a large portion of time now the
New York Times does a good job with a
lot of basic reporting but when it comes
to politics they're just pissing on your
face but there's a saying right and all
of these places are competing for the
same people I think the same because you
made it is saying
the Washington Post has major layoffs
right now I mean they're competing for
the same uh I want to say subscribers
but I don't remember what it's called
when it's actual print paper uh you know
they're competing for the same
subscription yeah they're competing for
the same people to pay for them that are
paying for the New York Times right and
if they're basically giving you the same
editorial positions on politics and
everything else and they're doing the
same type of reporting or maybe the New
York Times doing it better why would
people pay for their service right